[Musique]
eh bien le bonjour c'est le début de ce
premier jour à kyoto c'est incroyable il
est actuellement 6h30 du matin et je
vais aller au fond chimie inari taishan
j'ai fait un effort pour le nom pourquoi
est-ce qu'on y va aussitôt parce que les
touristes ça se reproduit evialis aux
nombreux après je mets ça vaut le coup
parce que là on va c'est magnifique
c'est l'endroit où vous savez il ya
plein de tous les rouges planté partout
mais que c'est beau lucas a arrêté
arrêté on n'est pas encore arrêté sauf
que quand il ya un touriste devant
chaque taureau rouge
ça fait des portes de touristes et ça ça
nous intéresse pas du tout vous propose
prendre un café au niveau pour les amis
je viens d'arriver et c'est extrêmement
beau war et voilà merci camion ça me
fait plaisir cache mes plans en fait
c'est un sanctuaire où les gens viennent
faire la prière et le passage très très
connue avec tous les taux les rouges
c'est plus haut en fait celle ordonnée
qui dure deux heures se retrouvent
autolib je vous donnerai les détails sur
ce que c'est voilà ce que je me suis
lancé je me suis documenté
[Musique]
oh
o o
[Musique]
oh
actuellement nous sommes au sommet du
mont inari au tout début de l'année il
ya environ 250000 japonais qui viennent
faire leurs premières prières ici aux
intentions saint-croix gros buzz mon
micro se débranche pendant que je parle
c'est incroyable coup je vais terminer
mes explications en moto doublant allez
c'est parti donc c'est aurait finalement
c'est quoi ces des hommes d'affaires et
des boîtes voilà qui les achètent nos
buts et au dos de chaque tories se
trouve le prénom du businessman ou de la
société qui les a achetées et pour avoir
tenté aurait hissés sur l'emplacement ça
peut coûter jusqu'à 10000 euros donc oui
là c'est genre 3000 euros et ce retour
c'est peut-être 5 euros sepa abonnez
vous voilà une petite surprise en
descendant de la montagne il est tombé
sur un café charte il fait je suis très
heureux au dessus de moyens john brook
[Musique]
d'où mon cv on en a eu six ans ici tout
oser au bois ils ont un délai avec mon
micro parce qu'il est touffu et ils ont
envie de croquer ou de lécher genre là
que de ce char où sont les micros c'est
la même matière regardez comme ils sont
mignons cela excellent papa ya qua non
pour ça qu'il ya de la du nutella la
cocagne à quoi qu'est ce qui les attire
ouais je vous ai vue auquel vous êtes en
train de voler de la nourriture lâchait
saussac honte aveux filmés qu'y at-il
dans cette petite fente un chat qui
regarde mal mariée bossu là aussi à ils
ont bien fait ton vêtements une réaction
à chaud
non ils sont adorables tu es un pc et tu
me rends un pv aux a failli au crochet
du gauche mais a joué une petite
réaction à chaud du vainqueur parfaite
des amis je suis devant le cndd joussen
kendo et je parle pas très fort comme
d'habitude parce que c'est les lieux
sacrés donc faut fermer sa gueule
en gros c'est quoi ces minimes en salle
dans laquelle il ya mille une statue de
la déesse bouddhique
il ya du coup sans rangées de dix
statues le truc hyper frustrant c'est
que c'est formellement interdit de
prendre des photos ou de filmer à
l'intérieur du coup vu que je prends
vraiment de risque pour les abonnés j'ai
pas fumer j'ai acheté un truc pour
touristes à 5 euros
et c'est juste une photo balla et voilà
et maintenant on va aller au qui ont mis
12 dollars nous venons de quitter qui
ont misé ou car il y avait extrêmement
beaucoup de monde à des gens partout des
touristes en kimono qui se prennent pour
des japonais japonais en kimono qui se
prennent pour des touristes savait plus
où se mettre
du coup on va paume tout chaud sur les
buts de l'époque même si les gens y
croient que c'est vraiment à l'époque
c'était le quartier des prostituées
c'est très très beau et surtout le soir
quand le soleil se couche il ya plein de
petites lanternes très très joli très
bien nous arrivons dans la rue pour une
faute au bonneteau de chocolat même s'il
fait jour les lanternes sont présentes
un excusez moi est ce que vous pouvez
laisser passer le professionnel chez ou
pleine discussion pardon excusez moi
pardon c'est donc une petite rues très
étroites que tu me laisser tranquille
s'il te plaît ici il ya un maximum de
petits restaurants et mais c'est une
lanterne la rue est très grande et très
très fine avec un max de lanterne des
absa parfois j'ai que cette anecdote
désolé alors pour deux choses c'est une
rue qui est dans le quartier de guns &
gun c'est un quartier très découle
pourquoi parce qu'on peut y croiser
plein de geisha et de maiko voilà comme
là bas derrière
et aussi des enfants courir et se
blesser dangereusement mais tout ça le
cas c'est intéressant mais tu vas faire
quoi dans ce quartier et ben moi je vous
propose de faire de la balançoire
moi je vais en faire une mais j'attends
keeper où je regarde d'un air menaçant
qui m'attend 30 minutes clairement c'est
une provocation de leur part ils veulent
pas nous fier la balançoire et ben on va
les agresser carrément
[Musique]
et ouais mon gars tu touches plus jamais
à notre terre ok computer florence ça
c'est une bataille de gang qui commence
ça va pas du tout il ya cru sa
centenaire basse il faut qu'on fasse un
truc territoire et voilà mon gars pour
tout ce qui existe et qui voulait
prendre possession de notre terre est
bon
à
je suis au king kakudji c'est le
pavillon d'or au japon en russie un
petit circuit à faire on peut pas
rentrer dedans et c'est hyper décevant
ça valait le tourisme comment voulez
vous que je travaille correctement avec
avec une famille alors pourquoi on est
venu ici puisque c'est juste à côté du
parc à saint girons valais après et
c'est quand même l'un des gros gros truc
avoir convient à kyoto au [ __ ] je
dérange les gens oui j'ai perdu mon duel
de caméra avec un japonais c'est un
grand moment plus tard il est beau donc
là bien sûr on peut voir les 1% qui
possèdent ce que les richesses du monde
et la classe moyenne ici présentes
représenté par ses cartes et finalement
c'est une leçon de vie le pavillon dans
son sac et bien alors juste ici le
pavillon invisible les eaux je me suis
toujours senti soutenu par ma famille
alors là tu peux lancer des pièces dans
un bol et si tu réussis ça porte chance
commence en ruine et en une lauzon
inutile d'acheter des sprinteurs août
venez au pavillon d'art basée en asie à
moi comme vous allez voir l'argent aux
abonnés il est bien investi on le lance
dans un bol attention du cac la réussite
n'est pas tout waouh
florent comme depuis le début de ta vie
j'étais encore battu un jeu ça va ça va
florent mais bien la forêt mais c'est
pas grave car d'un côté notre chemin et
on tombe sur quoi un deuxième vol ce qui
est bien c'est qu'ici ils veulent
vraiment tu dépends statut j'étais moins
de réactions à chaud
nous on jette pas l'argent par les
fenêtres angel dans un vol n'a pas papa
ok j'ai aperçu mon premier singe est
juste là il y en a un deuxième juste là
on part acheter de la bouffe et leur
tendant un artiste en action ouais c'est
cool ce qu'on va pouvoir les nourrir en
fait on va aller dans une cage celles
qui sont à l'extérieur et nous qui se
vend car j'arrivais gâteau n'est le coup
[Musique]
et c'est tellement mignon c'est un bébé
on avait le choix entre les pommes des
noix de cajou j'ai pris notre cage où
ils mangent tout retail et ya du monde
qui sera reine là mon pote
hop là c'est trop mignon comme une
prétendante à main en fait pour eux
c'est l'apéro quoi ils sont posés selon
millions au bla et je me casse en fait
dès qu'ils voient que des petits sachets
évident ils se cassent immédiatement
pour je viens d'acheter en sachet de
pommes parce qu'ils sont vraiment trop
mignon et mais lui il enchaîne les dix
ans mon gars
[Musique]
non mes mecs gros temps à manger 26 noms
n'ont aucun chèque mais je te donnerai
plus de morceaux donc tu peux acheter
des morceaux de pommes pour les jaunes
et aux charges
mon père a fait le choix de les manger
lui même moi je suis un singe en fait
combien le croire les amis le maître
dessin je viens de tous les appelés donc
je pense qu'il va tous les nourrir en
même temps ce qui promet de donner de
très belles images
[Musique]
après ce délai animalier rien de mieux
pour finir la journée que de visiter le
château de nidau venant il ya un énorme
palettes qu'ils étaient construits par
kylie japon il a été construit par le
yoga wakat kino couler où ils semblent
c'est pas plutôt l'ulti dans deux ans et
ce qui est cool c'est qu'au-delà du
château dans lequel je n'ai pas droit de
fumer bien sûr il ya plein de beaux
jardins et de beaux espaces rempli de
verdure et je propose qu'on se quitte
sur ça et bien écoutez j'espère que ce
petit bloc que vous a plu n'hésitez pas
à aimer f2 c'est le cas on se quitte sur
un petit moment musical desjardins denis
jo autres habitent
[Musique]
et